i mean what uh
from a biological perspective this might
be a dumb question but is there
parts of the virus that if uh
souped up like through mutation
could make it more effective at doing
his job we're talking about the specific
coronavirus like yeah because we were
talking about the different like the
membrane
the m protein the e protein the n
and the s the spike
is there some 20 or so more
in addition to that but is that is that
a dumb way to look at it like
uh which of these if mutated
could have the greatest impact
potentially
damaging impact on the effectiveness of
the virus so it's actually
it's a very good question uh because and
and the short answer is we don't know
yet
but uh of course there is capacity of
this virus to
to become more efficient the reason for
that
is um you know so if you look at the
virus i mean it's
it's a machine right so it's a machine
that does a lot of different functions
and many of these functions are sort of
nearly perfect but they are not perfect
and those mutations can make those
functions
more perfect for example the attachment
to
ace2 receptor right of the spike right
so uh
you know is it
has this virus reached the efficiency
in which the attachment is carried out
or there are some mutations that uh that
still to be discovered right that will
uh make this attachment
uh sort of uh stronger
or you know something uh
more in a way more efficient from the
point of view of this virus functioning
that's that's sort of uh the obvious
example but
if you look at each of these proteins i
mean it's there for a reason it performs
certain function
and uh it could be that
certain mutations will you know enhance
this function
it could be that some mutations will
make this function
much less efficient right so that's
that's also the case
you